[Musique]
avec une salve d'applaudissements
qui ici possède le téléphone portable, donc
évidemment c'est comme tout le monde maintenant
ici qui dirait que ce téléphone portable les a
mis dans des situations délicates avant
par exemple qu'un autre Poutine Anubis ne veuille se
concentrer sur les gens et même uber liens
akashi kaikyo  vignette Pineda p-speed
visconde de ville anova post Instagram
uma empathie alors développe Alicia linéaire limitée
elle a donc une cognition téléphonique ou
peut-être est-ce plus relatable qui a
déjà échappé à une situation délicate à
l'aide de son téléphone portable comme lorsque
vous regardez votre écran  donc vous
n'avez pas à établir un contact visuel avec cette
dame du travail que vous rencontrez à l'
épicerie mais vous ne voulez pas vraiment
parler mais c'est un peu gênant Je pense que c'est
fou ce que les gens sont prêts à faire pour
leurs téléphones portables  puis-je dessiner ou programmer
une heure et personne ne porte une
question de bons de devises qui est apparue
afin que Mabel Das Kapital tire le
nutella drôle de période - appuyez-vous sur otaku voyez maintenant
beaucoup de gens ar  Nous sommes conscients de cela, mais il est
possible que nous soyons dépendants de la
technologie, cela est dû à la
stimulation visuelle fournie par vous-même,
connue sous le nom de dopamine, qui déclenche une
substance libérée dans notre corps qui
produit ce que nous appelons du plaisir. La
même substance est également  libéré lorsque nous
mangeons, buvons de l'alcool ou prenons des drogues,
il est donc physiquement possible que
nous soyons dépendants de la stimulation technologique.
Non seulement nous sommes
probablement tous dépendants, mais nous éprouvons également
des symptômes de sevrage lorsque nous
ne regardons pas nos écrans lorsque nous sommes
absent  de nos téléphones, la plupart d'entre nous diront que
nous nous sentons seuls déprimés, anxieux ou
bouleversés, ces émotions peuvent être associées
au manque de dopamine dans notre corps, d'
accord, passons à une autre
salve d'applaudissements
qui utilisent ici leurs téléphones portables pour
faire défiler facebook Instagram
snapchat ou  YouTube
[Applaudissements]
maintenant, qui ici a déjà été témoin d'insultes
ou d'arguments basés sur des différences culturelles, raciales,
sociales et politiques sur ces
plates-formes  Cela ne vous surprendra
donc pas, mais ce type de comportement en ligne
est connu sous le nom de cyberintimidation et plus de 70
% des adolescents québécois rapporteront y avoir été
exposés
.  la norme sociale
n'est-il pas plus facile de simplement republier des
retweets ou de réagir
au lieu de refuser de rejeter et de
regretter en plus lorsque nous sommes
constamment exposés à ces comportements négatifs et de
jugement, nous sommes évidemment
sujets à de multiples
instabilités émotionnelles telles que la dépression ou
les troubles anxieux même si la plupart
les personnes concernées ne l'admettront jamais ou ne le
sauront jamais Je pense que personne
ici n'a besoin d'être convaincu qu'il
existe de nombreux avantages à la technologie,
mais nous avons atteint un point où les
inconvénients sont devenus plus apparents
et plus importants dans notre vie quotidienne
technologie  nous dérange constamment,
il joue un grand rôle dans notre capacité à nous
concentrer sur notre motivation  ation de
participer à des activités non technologiques
et au final je pense qu'il est
juste de dire que la technologie nous a volé l'
isolement du reste du monde
tout cela pour dire que nous devons changer
nos habitudes technologiques c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui je présente non  phone Tuesday
set activity abdomen akiko kyst in
Arizona - Antonio complete in Quebec mmm
Apple boob the new datasheet burn
objective is a CL an OB de Toledo a de
novo met with deep a décidé de les
technologic avant que quiconque ne commence à
critiquer cette initiative Je
voudrais souligner  dehors que ce n'est pas une
base totalement volontaire notre éducation la
santé mentale et la forme physique sont régulièrement
affectées par la technologie c'est pourquoi je
vous demande de ranger le téléphone une fois par
semaine car cela a pris trop de
temps et trop d'importance dans notre  vit
déjà
maintenant allez-vous participer merci
[Applaudissements]